okay so here's the shell of the code
that we saw before
where we're grabbing the click location
on the document which is just the whole
website and we're going to be running
some steps using this weird function
syntax that we'll actually be learning a
little bit more about soon every time
the page is clicked we create two new
variables x and y
both of them use this location object
this location event object from the
click and we grab its page x and it's
page y which are simply the pixel values
of the x and y location of the clicks
once we have the x and y locations we
simply pass them into log clicks and we
should see
when we click there it is again
x and y locations